martin biron hélène buzzati michel
sauget bonsoir c'est inévitable à chaque
fois que le gouvernement propose annonce
devrait agir d assouplissement il ya
davantage de mécontents dans la société
civile des gens des commerçants le vieux
monsieur boudreau et paul bonne humeur
ils disent écoutez là ça suffit pas on
n'en peut plus et c'est l'équilibré dur
à aller chercher
prenons le cas des cinémas je vous
entends de là dessus parce que monsieur
legault 10 pour les enfants il faut
laisser un peu d'oxygène permettre aux
parents d'aller voir un film et que leur
petit jeu guzzo dis-moi j'ouvrirai pas
je peux pas vendre de pop corn la minus
qui est prise on veut l'entendre
nathalie roy avant de vous donner la
parole qui dit ouais mais là si on
permet au cinéma devant du pack web et
des jupes lee imaginez la réaction des
restaurants en écoute
nous sommes toujours en zone rouge donc
en zone rouge
on doit avoir ce couvre-feu qui est
efficace on l'a vu parce que ça fait
diminuer le nombre de cas cependant nos
restaurants novare sont toujours fermées
et il ne faut pas que nos cinémas
deviennent en quelque sorte des
restaurants ne peut pas y manger non
plus c'est pour voir des files c'est la
logique qui sous tendait la décision de
la santé publique
c'est comme les jeux martin là on était
plus jeunes dont on tape sur une
boulette on pense avoir réglé point il y
en a trois autres qui manque c'est c'est
sans fin la yann grande d'un million
sais même pas si les cinémas vont ouvrir
quoi en tout cas si tous des membres et
s'est plaint des conduites et là c'est
pas d'hyères lorsqu'il y en a depuis des
semaines et des semaines je suis gelé
publiés tous ce serait pas mal est fait
je trouve
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant en entrevue
vous avez fait avec monsieur guzzo parce
que ça nous donne une idée de avec quel
genre de balle
est ce qu'on doit jongler
au bureau du premier ministre et le
premier ministre lui-même monsieur
legault déjà dit dans une conférence de
presse
il ya plusieurs semaines qu'il y avait
perdu beaucoup d'amis pendant cette
pandémie
alors c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent des choix mais sont dans une
situation où on dit gouverner c'est
prévoir mais c'est aussi décider
monsieur legault voulait faire un peu d
espace pour les jeunes c'est sûr que si
tu ouvres tout ça fait 100 % des gens
qui circulent si tu ouvres la moitié 50%
des gens qui circulent le tiers c'est
hier des gens qui circulent a lancé ça
le choix qui a été fait il y en a qui
gagnent il y en a qui perdent
est ce qu'on veut c'est une relâche
potable alors c'est la situation
c'est ça mais celle ci c'est que ça les
commerçants pieds encore une fois la
bombe je voudrais pas de ça le regarde
mais on les comprend les restaurateurs
on les comprend ils peuvent plus c'est
dur cette crise là en même temps qu'un
d'autres secteurs ouvre l'oeil ça les
fait réagir d'autant plus là michel way
à chaque fois qu'on ouvre quelque chose
quelque chose alors pourquoi pour moi
les cinémas ouvrir toutes les troupes de
théâtre au québec disent hey pourquoi
pas nous autres on exactement la même
configuration des salles
il faut juste éviter de ce2 de créer des
petites irritations pas nécessaire
monsieur guzzo ce n'est pas la fin du
monde je pense que c'est pas drôle quand
même si je pense qu'on peut acheter des
nachos occident si si ça veut dire que
s'ils demeurent espère mais ça vaut pas
la peine d'avoir cette exception mais
c'est un fait on consulte en construit
l'avion en plein vol
à chaque fois qu'ils vont avoir un
relâchement quelque part quelqu'un
d'oise et moi aussi
moi j'aurais pu - moi j'ai les mêmes
configurations et on a fini pas alors
c'est une décision que le gouvernement
prend au mieux de ce qu'il pense
par exemple pourquoi les t shirts ont
été à peu près vers est décidément oui
parce que gouvernement dit il ya pas
tant si jolie le faire demain matin vous
serez prêt de toute façon ce dernier de
prêts à mettre à l'affiché pendant la
semaine de relâche
les rendre à cette fin pour le vieux
mais c'est clair que surtout avec le
temps qui s'est passé et le nombre de
jeunes qui ont été privés de revenus
tout le monde doit dire hey mais aussi
avec les gens sont à cran et on peut
comprendre il faut pas oublier que la
raison pour laquelle vous pouvez ne pas
parler de la chose et je dirais même
aussi des hot dogs et bien d'autres
choses
c'est pour s'assurer que tout le monde
conserve son mas il ya aussi cet aspect
là donc ils pas totalement incongru à
mon avis et on comprend les
propriétaires de cinémas qui en rendant
leur fortune à 8 10 $ cessé une partie
très très très sain de leurs profits
ouais mais c'est certain qu'il ya des
incongruités au je pense qu'il est à peu
près impossible d'y échapper comme comme
le soulignait martin l'idée c'est qu'on
peut pas tout réouvrir en même temps
alors nécessairement ont fait des choix
qui reflète les priorités du jour en ce
moment plaire aux petits-enfants qui
n'auront rien à faire pendant ces neuf
jours là mais si on commence à être
cohérent ça nous amènerait à l'ouverture
de tellement d'autres commerces et où
restera que finalement contreviendrait à
notre propre objectif l'incohérence et
un peu cohérente en quelques sortes
voilà je vous fais entendre l'opposition
sur les assouplissements plus plus
d'ordre général on dit y'a pas de
barrages mais on y va en plus de
policiers ce qu'on s'interroge on va les
écouter et on revient pas uniquement se
baser sur la dénonciation la
dénonciation de deux voisins ou de gens
du voisinage ou de la communauté de
gouvernement doit faire la démonstration
à travers
en collaboration avec l'école claude
comment ils vont s'y prend des verts
rien tel que vous l'amenez exige que le
gouvernement du québec pose des gestes
notamment en matière de déplacements
d'une région à l'autre
est ce là dessus moi j'ai pas été
satisfait de la réponse
les gens des régions prêté sept des
régions orange on peut être satisfait
des réponses on met cette responsabilité
là dans les mains des policiers des
hôteliers d'aider des milieux
touristiques et je trouve que c'est un
manque de responsabilité de la part d'un
gouvernement qui doit qui doit être
celui qui prend des décisions tranchées
tran chinh celle ci aux gestes qu'on
laisse entendre qu'on aurait voulu dit
l'opposition que le gouvernement dise
vous irez peut louer des chalets dans
une zone orange il rester dans votre
seconde points mais on sait édition fait
ça ce que vraiment ça va être possible
de mettre ça en pratique ou pas
j'imagine michel d'une part essayer ces
postures qu'on peut seulement être
imprécis que d'autres variables et blanc
qui ont l'ouïe des chalets plusieurs
semaines et plusieurs gros à l'avance en
sachant la date de la salle de la
semaine de relâche
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces gens
note troisièmement les ressources
policières que ça prendrait pour mettre
des vrais barrage entre les régions
ce serait absolument énorme ce serait
l'équivalent d'avoir la la frontière
canado américaine
si on veut que ce soit et h or tout le
monde sait que ça peut pas être étage on
peut peut-être avoir quelque chose le
dissuasif
et d'ailleurs quand tu as eu des
barrages dans la première vague c'est
dissuasif iem deux voitures que c'était
pas très contraignant donc encore une
fois on fait pour le mieux dans les
circonstances
et on peut pas empêcher des gens qui de
bonne foi all away j'allais y aurait
peut-être pas dû mais il ya loin chalet
ya trois ans mourant où il ya quatre
mois de dire on va on va suivre les
conseils hélène d'ailleurs votre région
a été rétrogradé
à la couleur orange est donc les
restaurants vont rouvrir en outaouais
est-ce que les gens d'après vous sont
craintifs de voir arriver soit des
montréalais où des gens d'ailleurs
ben c'est pas comme si les montréalais
ont l'habitude des mets beaucoup
l'outaouais donc elle n'est pas très
présente mais ici c'est ce set ce
passage du rouge aux orangers titre très
bien accueilli parce que c'était vécu
cette zone rouge comme une aberration le
depuis de nombreuses semaines parce que
le nombre de coptes avaient par capital
par par cent mille habitants pardon est
très inférieure à celle des hommes qui
étaient déjà orange je pense par exemple
aux salines et hong hao la moitié moins
de poids que la boe eux est en rage pour
la gaspésie aussi plus de coque nous
évidemment c'est en lien avec le fait
que notre situation frontalière ici fait
en sorte que notre système de santé est
plus fragile et un exode d'emploi est de
travers de la santé et donc ça nous
prend goût à un col pour nous fragiliser
mais néanmoins il est le maire de
gatineau aussi qu'ils méritaient
vraiment qu'ils demandaient ce passage à
orange
donc c'est très active et très bien
accueilli il faut savoir aussi que de
l'autre côté de la rivière l'ontario la
route vers ces commerces mardi ses choix
et donc l'os à arrêter complètement
inutile de continuer les lits fermés
aussi parce que les gens auraient juste
fait quelques mètres pour aller au
restaurant quand même oui martin sur ces
questions de barrage de travail policier
tous sont à jonglei toutes sortes
d'hypothèses
puis michel le djia s'est clairement on
est arrivé donc à la conclusion que
c'était irréaliste d'établir des
frontières étanches
il faut aussi on comprendre quand on a
rangé effectivement des réticences mais
ça n'est pas que vous parler parce qu'il
ya des gens qui veulent que leur chalet
soit loué que leur chambre d'hôtel joue
à louer et qui espérait qu et qui
doivent entrer et les barrages cc c'est
un peu contre productif parce que si tu
sur ton peu de gens beaucoup de gens
sains dans une région pour des raisons
qui sont mus
type là et qui sont pas juste de relâche
des fois c'est juste aller voir un
proche
allez dans leur famille dans leur belle
famille où on fait telle oui au tour là
où les résidences secondaires ne devrait
pas dire je sais la belle famille parce
que vous devrez payer l'émir mais enfin
il ya toutes sortes de raisons qui fait
que les gens vont se promener d'une
région à l'autre et le barrage c'est un
symbole à certains égards parce que une
fois que t'as pas si tu t'en vas t'on
chalet si tu vois sur un site dans une
zone de chalets tu peux bien de faire un
feu en soirée et fraterniser avec
d'autres familles de chalais alors que
si tu crains que la police vienne faire
un tour sur le site où ça lui bella
était beaucoup plus de style
puis ces mails de l'âme sur le coup leur
répéter hier ça il peut avoir des
contractions 2002 là si vous vous
retrouvez dans une adresse qui n'est pas
votre adresse à fraterniser bonne bonne
idée il reste quatre minutes pas du
français la langue française hélène je
commence avec vous la ministre joly qui
veut symboliquement dépassé en tout cas
devant ces jeux les barrettes du mois je
vais agir pour les entreprises qui sont
sous la juridiction la fédérale d'un
char gé néral télécommunications machin
pour m'inspirer de la loi sans qu est ce
que vous comprenez de ce qu'elle veut
faire de moi j'ai pas encore vu ce qui
sera fait alors on met tout ça avec des
bémols mais bon clairement pour le
québec ça ne touche pas énormément de
travail en les estimer qu'on voit passer
on parle d'à peu près 75 mille
travailleurs sont dans ce genre
d'entreprise de compétence fédérale qui
ne sont pas aussi lise laura des voix
soit la langue officielle la loi sur les
langues officielles d'ottawa où la loi
101 au québec donc peu de monde mais ça
veut pas dire que c'est inutile
ce que je vois ici à peut-être une
stratégie parce qu'on savait que québec
allait peut-être être agacé qu'ottawa
passe par sa loi sur les langues
officielles plutôt que la loi québécoise
sur la grosseur et donc on voyait
peut-être un affrontement entre les deux
niveaux de gouvernement se profile à
l'horizon le ce que madame joly sans
vouloir faire c'est dire ou de mon rôle
phare pour le québec mais aussi pour les
francophones qu'ils sont
dans des milieux minoritaires par
exemple le nord de l'ontario et le
nouveau-brunswick sas est susceptible de
plaire à bien les francophones hors
québec et donc ottawa peut-être est en
train de dire québec si t'es pas content
chic en toi avec les francophones hors
québec mais pas avec moi donc c'est
comme une pâte est une stratégie de
déplacer le fond de bataille si vous
voulez pour ce pourra être au dessus de
la mêlée donc ça va peut-être réussir
est ce une stratégie michel surgit pour
dire que le parti libéral du canada à
une autre une autre approche vis-à-vis
la protection de la langue française par
rapport à l' approche historique non oui
absolument que d'un discours du trône y
avait quelque chose qui était qui était
d'y danser le gouvernement fédéral ont
le devoir de protéger le français non
seulement à l'extérieur du québec mais
au québec il ya une espèce de fait de la
symétrie la dgda qui est très importante
l'asymétrie légal va rester les deux
langues officielles sont sur le même
pied et elles doivent le rester mais
c'est quand même un fait que dans la
réalité des choses
la situation du français pour la
situation de la règle est au canada ce
pas même à ce pas la même chose au
gouvernement fédéral dit on doit
s'occuper de ça et donc utilisée dans
les fêtes le à peu près les détails mais
à peu près les mots de la loi 101 les
mécanismes de la loi et les mettre dans
la loi sur les langues officielles pour
qu'elle s'applique aux compagnies de
juridiction fédérale
le père de monsieur trudeau a fait une
syncope diabétiques sont fait frissonner
il ya quelque chose d'assez d'assez de
nouveau là dedans et on verra si ça
passe
si la loi est adoptée elle a fait qu'il
est donc c'est pour des versions comme
ça la nouvelle génération de libéraux
fédéraux francophones du québec veulent
avoir un dossier plus facile à vendre au
québec où si haut martin bureau ce qui
nous ramène à genève arrête sa réforme
liés à servier après la relâche c'est ça
va être très rapide
oui on se rend relâche à partir de
demain on est de retour la chambre d'à
le retour le 9 mars après la relâche et
c'est pas dans la semaine du 9 mars et
dans la semaine suivante ça ça ça sinon
je vous le dis ça swingue réforme
québécoises présentes et mime assez
rapidement oui ça va venir la très
rapide bir ont très bien bon l'erreur on
l'a entendu ici en premier merci
beaucoup à vous trois pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit